وقال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
الولايات المتحده واضحه وثابته في موقفها
بشان رفضها القاطع لاي تقليص لمساحه قطاع
غزه واضاف كيربي في مؤتمر صحفي في البيت
الابيض ان بلاده ترفض ايضا اي دور لحماس
وقادتها في اي شكل من اشكال الحكم بغزه
بعد الحرب حسب
تعبيره
لقد كنا واضحين وثابتين على موقفنا سرا
وعلانيه باننا لا نريد ان نرى تقليصا
لمساحه غزه باي شكل من الاشكال ومهما كان
شكل مستقبل الحكم في غزه ما بعد الصراع
فيجب ان يكون معبرا عن تطلعات الشعب
الفلسطيني الذي لا تمثله حماس ولا يمكن ان
يتضمن قادتها فاغلب الفلسطينيين لا يؤيدون
ما تسببت فيه حركه حماس
من واشنطن تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره وجد
وقفي ومن مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك
مراسل الجزيره مراد هاشم البدايه معك
وجد ما م رد هذا الموقف الذي عبر
عنه بلينكن وكيربي بالتزامن وهو رفض المس
بمساحه قطاع
غزه
يعني يا حسن هذه التصريحات لكل من وزير
الخارجيه ولجان كيربي كانت ردا على اسئله
صحفيين حول تقرير نيويورك تايمز الذي اورد
بان اسرائيل تعتزم انشاء منطقه امنيه
عازله بعمق كيلومتر على طول حدودها مع غزه
البيت الابيض كان واضحا جدا وصريحا على
لسان جون كيربي الذي اكد معارضته لايه
محاوله لقدم اراضي القطار او تقليص حجم
اراضي قطاع غزه قال ان الرئيس بايدن كان
واضحا بهذا الشان والبيت الابيض ظل يكرر
موقفه وهو عازم على التمسك بهذا الموقف
وهو الموقف الرافض ل تقليص مساحه قطاع غزه
او قضم اراضي القطاع تحت ايه طريقه وباي
شكل بحسب قول كيربي هو ردد هذا هذا
التصريح اكثر من من مره في الاحاطه التي
كانت اليوم بلينكن من جانبه حقيقه بدا
ملفتا ترديده لموقف الاداره الامريكيه
المعروف وهو ليس جديدا ومنذ اليوم الاول
ومنذ ان بدات حكومه الحرب لنتنياهو تتحدث
عن اقامه منطقه امنيه عازله اداره بايدن
ظلت تبين ب بشكل واضح جدا في جميع
تصريحاتها معارضتها ل هذا المخطط
الاسرائيلي وبانها ضد هذا المخطط وبانه لا
ينبغي ان تخسر غزه الشبر من اراضيها
وينبغي ان تحكمها السلطه فلسطينيه لكن
يعني
بلينكن رغم اعلانه الرفض للتغيير الدائم
للوضع الجغرافي لكنه اعتبر ان الامر يكون
مختلفا اذا كانت هناك ضروره لترتيبات
انتقاليه ماذا يعني
ذلك
وهذا هو الجديد حسن هذا هو الجديد وهذا هو
الملفت في هذا الموقف اذا كان بلينكن
يتحدث باسم الاداره الامريكيه ممثله
بالبيت الابيض الذي لم يتطرق اليوم الى اي
حديث عن ترتيبات انتقاليه فاذا هذا يعتبر
تحول وتغير في موقف هذه الاداره لانها كما
قال كيربي هي لم تغير موقفها الثابت ازاءه
بان الوضع في غ غزه وضع حدود الاراضي
الفلسطينيه في غزه لا ينبغي ان يتغير او
مساحه الجغرافيه لقطاع غزه اما اذا كان
بلينكن يتحدث بشكل منفرد فهذا مختلف هذا
ربما يشير الى عدم تناسق او تماشي المواقف
في الخارجيه والبيت الابيض بدا حقيقه
مفاجئا هذا التصريح للرئيس الامريكي لكل
من تابعوا تصريح جون كيربي في البيت
الابيض تصريح وزير الخارجيه امريكي جاء
بهذه الاضافه الملفته والمهمه جدا ترتيبات
انتقاليه وهو كان يقصد واوضح بلينك خلال
حديثه عن الترتيبات الانتقاليه بانها من
اجل عوده الالاف او مئات الالاف من
الاسرائيليين الذين نزحوا عن اماكن سكناهم
طبعا في غلاف غزه على اذري السابع من
اكتوبر هو يعتبر ان ذلك سوف يكون وضعا
مؤقتا بلينكن وبانه لا ي معارض هذا الوضع
ولكن من اجل ان يصبح هذا الوضع المؤقت
قائما ينبغي فعليا ازاله جميع البيوت
المنازل الفلسطينيه المباني السكنيه
الفلسطينيه وغيرها مباني الخدمات
الفلسطينيه هناك وبالتالي هذا الامر لن
يكون مؤقتا في حال بالفعل تمت ازاله كل
هذه المباني من اجل هذه المنطقه ولكن هناك
تاكيد واضح وثابت من هذه الاداره بانها ضد
انشاء حكومه نتنياهو منطقه امنه داخل
اراضي غزه تدمير هذه البيوت وهذه المباني
وجد اعتبرها المقرر الاممي المعني
بالاسكان اعتبرها بانها تصل الى مستوى
جريمه حرب ماذا في هذا الموقف مراد هاشم
للمقرر الاممي المعني
بالاسكان نعم حسن هو يتسق مع موقف ال
الامم المتحده اجمالا
بمختلف مستوياتها موقف الامانه العامه
الامين العام
ومساعيه الاغلبيه اعضاء مجلس الامن الدولي
ان لم يكن الجميع كما سمعنا الان الموقف
الامريكي وسمعناه سابقا مرارا
وتكرارا ايضا الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده رفض لاي انتقاص من اراضي غزه او
اعاده احتلال اي شبر من اراضي غزه وكذلك
رفض اي تدمير ممنهج وواسع
للمساكن في القطاع وفي هذا السياق تاتي
المقابله التي اجرتها نيويورك تايمز في
اطار تقريرها بهذا الشان والذي في الواقع
تنقل فيه عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين من ان
هناك خطه تنفذ من اجل اقامه منطقه امنه من
الواضح ان انها مرفوضه دوليا كما نتابع
المواقف ولذلك على ما يبدو تنفذ بهذه
السريه رغم ان هناك
تلميحات سابقه لمسؤولين اسرائيليين بهذا
الشان بالا كريشن راجا جوبال وهو المقرر
الاممي لشؤون
الاسكان الملائم وهو حقوقي امريكي وايضا
متخصص في شؤون حقوق الانسان وال قضايا
النزوح كان واضحا حينما قال ان التدمير
الممنهج والواسع للمساكن قد يرقى الى
جريمه حرب ومن انه لا يوجد اي تهديد مباشر
لهذه المساكن لامن اسرائيل وانه قد يكون
مفهوما اذا ما طالت عمليه التدمير لاسباب
امنيه
منزلا منازل منفرده ولكن هذا التدمير
الواسع هو خرق
لاتفاقيات اتفاقيه جنيف الرابعه التي تحدد
مسؤوليات سلطه القوى ال القائمه بالاحتلال
اذا ال ال
الناس الخاضعين لسلطتها وبطبيعه
الحال المقرر الاممي يشير هنا الى ان
عمليه التدمير الواسعه هذه مخالفه لهذه
الاتفاقيه وبطبيعه الحال هو يرفضها ويحذر
منها
اليوم ونحن نتابع الجلسه المنعقده حاليا
في مجلس الامن الدولي وهي وهو الاجتماع
الربع السنوي وفيه يشارك ثلا 20 من رؤساء
نواب رؤساء الوزراء ووزراء الخارجيه
ووكلاء الوزراء مستوى مهم من التمثيل
سمعنا فيما يتعلق بمساله ضروره
ال ان ان يكون هناك الاحترام للقانون
الدولي وكذلك لحقوق الفلسطينيين فيما
يتعلق ب ارضهم ايضا سمعنا الامين العام
للمتحده يشير تحديدا الى نسبه الدمار الذي
تعرضت له المساكن في قطاع غزه و سمعنا
ايضا من اكثر من متحدث ما يتعلق بالوضع
الذي بات فيه من المستحيل على السكان
العوده للحياه بشكل طبيعي فيما يتعلق
بالقطاع كاملا وليس فقط الشريط الحدودي
الذي تحاول اسرائيل ان تقيم فيه منطقه
عازله كما
تسعى شكرا جزيلا لك مراد هاشم من مقر
الامم المتحده في نيويورك وشكرا لوجد وقفي
كانت معنا من واشنطن
m